une production du studio sf
mais amenés au sans filtre le podcast on
parle de ce qu'ont fait nos invités date
seach bh cantet avec moins d'hommes
plantes je le sais votre résolution 2022
c'est de partir en podcast est bien il
n'y a pas de meilleure place que le
studio sf vous arriver si vous vous
occuper de votre contenu et nous on se
charge de tout le reste les techniciens
le matériel la connaissance technique
production post production tout ce que
vous voulez deux jours ouvrables après
avoir ajusté votre podcast vous l'avez
dans votre boîte courriel en vidéo et
audio fait avec ce que vous voulez bref
si vous voulez plus d'information allez
au studio 7 points c'est à certains en
font le lancez vous lancez votre projet
vous prenez lui vous avez permet là un
autre niveau studio aussi bon cette
semaine on reçoit marc andré campagne à
1 go à l'entrepreneur qui est la vision
que la drive comme j'en ai rarement vu
dans ma vie on l'aura compris récemment
à travers amis d'amis pour le tri son
histoire tellement intéressant tellement
intrigante puis il recrutement inspirant
que le dysfonctionnement faire un
podcast avec toi donc je pense que vous
allez messieurs surtout s'intéresser à
la 19 ans qu'au final je pense vraiment
que vous allez adorer ou juste si vous
intéressez à la vie ouais en fait sur la
compagnie de marc-andré qui s'appelle
roxio d'une compagnie de
télécommunications qui est là pour
chéque et le statu quo dans l'industrie
la télécommunication puis il nous
raconte comment sa partie puis c'est
vraiment fascinant c'est que on va les
remettre aux commanditaires sans plus
attendre puis bon paquet le podcast
semaine et présenté par memscap si vos
bases ont l'air la barbe du père noël
c'est le temps de passer chez mindscape
on a ici dans mes mains le landreau 4.0
qui la clippers par excellence pour les
bases pour la barbe pour n'importe
quelle partie du corps ses ouailles
retrouve donc dans la douche bottes des
gosses ces skins itunes kinek
technologies vous empêche de vous [ __ ]
ici moi c'est le culpabiliser pour tous
doit aussi penser qu'ils bossent lice
pour tous utilisent pourtant que je rase
pas mon cher
ça vidal prefect à quel point zéro avec
les batchs heures avec le club varois
qui glandent si ton honneur pour les
bases avec des os pour les bases tout
seul et moi avec les craquements
personne mais que j'utilise
régulièrement besoin d'un petit coup de
nettoyants sur les parties de
rafraîchissant pour avec meilleur jeu
que garder son frère cadet c'est une
belle petite odeur puis c'est toujours
pratique d'avoir un patronyme ion plein
de promo pour le temps des fêtes si vous
voulez acheter un cadeau à votre être
cher c'est le temps de le faire puis
vous pouvez aussi utiliser notre code
promo qui le sans filtre pour 20% de
rabais et le shipping gratuit / tu es là
tu sais le temps d'utiliser un même
script d'acheter minsk est de faire le
don de la propres tubes de
l'ecofin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
yes marque merci d'être là le plaisir
qu'on arrive on y est alors on parlait
juste avant deux ans on a retenu un
sujet qui s'amenait croustillant juste
avant de rentrer en ont marre fond tu
nous expliquer que tes parents empêché
de faire la pelouse par peur que tu
brises la tondeuse et de l'eau et neoxia
[Rires]
l'histoire mais c'est c'est pratiquement
vrai en fait c'est que c'est vrai que
j'ai bien fait de la pelouse de ma vie
puis c'est encore un chip one man show
de recueillir encore aujourd'hui qu'un
jour faucher canard court de tondeuse
pour apprendre comment content de tomber
mais a fait option est venu au monde en
2010 est ça s'appelait accès télécom on
voulait démocratiser l'accès internet en
région que mes parents moi je suis de
québec vous êtes cap rouge on déménage
ap rouge on se construit une écurie
dessus il réaliser leur rêve de prendre
la retraite pis vu que le raf de retrait
c'est un écu rire pour une écurie à
projets des chevaux dans leur cote monte
à bois pour chasser sur le terrain lyon
bat du plaisir qu'ils avaient beaucoup
de travail manuel il refuser la maison
sont complets beaucoup de choses à faire
puis vu que moi je suis aux manuels pic
mais mes parents ont peur pour ma vie
quand je prends mon auto quand je touche
à n'importe quoi qui est physique ils
m'ont dit mais occupe toi de l'internet
de la maison de connecter à internet a
raison puis j'ai fait des recherches
puis avait juste un fournisseur de
disponible qui était telle est la seule
vitesse qui étaient disponibles ces
trois méga bits seconde à 75 pièces par
mois trop mégabits/seconde le
en est à 2007 c'est vraiment
à montréal le film existe entre la haute
vitesse existait déjà des centres
urbains oui la fiv existait déjà mais
encore des secteurs à montréal le capot
de la firme je sens la maison aussi en
corse il ya encore beaucoup de travail à
faire à ce niveau le mais à pau où je
vais encore plus de travail mais
c'est long mais n'est sûr
-selon pis le débat c'est fou qui
convainc les autres membres de ta
famille de prostituées mais
non ils prennent tout la benoîte
fake fait que ses soeurs fait que c'est
comme ça puis moi je connaissais
absolument rien dans l'industrie des
télécommunications chez entrevoir de
plus j'ai 14 ans c'était ma troisième
compagnie au xi e on va faire on faire
une petite pause juste le way se croient
que les autres compagnies avant 14 ans à
14 heures
mais j'ai importé du fourrage de chine
toutes les ligues jerry brown puis à
québec j'avais une équipe de vente dans
toutes les écoles secondaires de québec
comment résoudre je ne sais pas ce
que vous ne vous y accueille nice mais
12 et 15 20 30 puis 28 fait peut-être
que vous avez déjà vu des polos lacoste
dans le temps avec des fils de pêche des
écoles le monde ça les joueurs de hockey
principalement ch et se dit c'est moi
qu'ils ont importés de la chine en fait
tu sais rien je te le dis mon père
premier coup que j'ai fait ma première
commande je me rappelle encore j'ai
trois mille dollars puis à l'époque pour
payer en chine la seule chose que tu
peux faire c'est d'aller au est une
union ok pour transférer l'argent
c'était la seule méthode puis fallait
que 18 ans fait qu'il fallait je disais
à mon appareil page et 3000 pièces
d'enlever les jeunes entreprises
regardent je parle son message bas je
passerai msn avec une madame la boxe va
nous aider à face il faudra envoyer
trois mille dollars
puis mon sérieux message d'incroyance
connaissance que c'était pas un scam sa
fable les gens
en fait j'étais très évasif au début
j'avais peur que mon père me dise non
pour des ch'ti vélo qui est ou qui
soient forts chez ou quoi que ce soit
fait qu au début mon père au contraire
quand on s'est assis autour de la table
pour parler de les dépenser que je
vendais de la drogue parce que vu le 3 m
$ avec je parle de l'idée
je parlais des mécènes tu sais mes
parents sont pas très techno plus que
ceux plus qu'un plus qu'une autre un
autre parent fait qu ils m'ont pas été
comme marc-andré ce qu'est ce que tu vas
de la drogue à l'école qu'est-ce que tu
pourquoi le lien est fait rire savez
polo lacoste
sort tellement mal étrange qui dépasse
mais fait que c'est comme ça j'ai fait
ça de 14 passes et 1,7 à dessus comme ça
tu bien maîtrise de l'environnement on
faisait je fais moi en fait comment ça
marche il sait je parlais avec la fiq
avait un c'était en tout cas c'est un
site que je peux aller voir les prix moi
je faisais plus 50% je vends des sceaux
ou secondaire j'avais des équipes de
vente qu'il prenait une commission puis
on ne distribue ce genre est
académicien louis ssf cardinal away les
deux écoles tout elle y est j'ai fait
trois écoles secondaires
enfin quelqu'un qui me poignard
distribue la marque a
fait que j'ai fait l'académie
saint-louis ssf puis
compagnons-de-cartier après philippe
métais effect a vendu à cardy nous
autres on était à quatre on
en avait on avait un gosse pages mal
apple cuite sont en vacances qui va dès
lors on avait singapour dans le temps on
avait
battu mettant le titre indicatif le cpie
oblige être précis mais c'est quoi ton
chiffre d'affaires de cette entreprise
le letton a faim on faisait du dans le
pays faisait les commandes d'à peu près
6000 euros par mois j'osais pas loin de
50 % de marge là-dessus
fait grossesse puis ma deuxième rapport
fait arrêter pourquoi détachées sorties
de seconde si ça puis à un moment donné
c'est juste que les gens se sont acquis
qu'on vendait se sont toutes mis à soi
l'équipe de vente que j'avais fait ont
décidé voler de leurs propres ailes puis
commander directement chez nous les gens
ont trouvé les sites qui ont décidé de
commander parlement et m'exclure a pu
tisser mes deux premières entreprises
étaient vraiment plus dmc pas vraiment
des entreprises c'est plus travailleur
un homme qui fait quelque chose par
l'humain et c'était pas quelque chose
qui pouvait ski et l'épi crée de la
valeur pour d'autres personnes qui
créent de la propriété intellectuelle ou
quoi que ce soit comme on fait avec
la deuxième la deuxième je devais des
événements dans les morts à travers le
québec ça s'appelait québec parce que
juillet moi je moi je sais qu'il peut
plus de l'administration tout simplement
parce que plus le la personnalité
publique de ces événements alj pas je
peux dire en sortir je n'aime pas
beaucoup les les grands événements
publics avec plein de vie plein de monde
puis je faisais ça quand même mais j'ai
énormément appris fait qu aux pays qui
sont faisait des événements de comme on
en faisait 30 par mois pour un mec je
voyageais partout 30 événements par
moore quoi 31 $ mois on a fait de venir
à montréal on ne fait une coupe moria
c'était comme la région qu'on en faisait
le moins mais à montréal en effet devenu
aussi 'future' puis du cidj et
des événements nos bouquets ces artistes
l'heure je me rappelle plus en quelle
année fait que j'ai fait ça au québec
dalphond l'entrepreneuriat tu avais su
depuis tout le temps si tu reviens tu ta
famille issue
géographe amis
m'ont prêté des cadres spécialisés puis
ma mère est cadre dans les systèmes la
santé donc j'ai vraiment aucun
entrepreneur pour la famille par contre
moi je suis né à beckham où j'ai grandi
à prayssac québec et 4e année puis
étrangement dans mon parcours tous mes
meilleurs amis en grandissant leur part
est entrepreneur puis on dirait que de
voir les parents de mes amis plat là le
type de prestance qui dégage et puis le
respect dans leur communauté j'ai
toujours admiré je trouvais ça vraiment
cool jallet supprimer ton chez mes amis
puis je me ramasse à parler plus souvent
avec leur part que le reste du monde
poser des questions c'est ça m'a
toujours vraiment vraiment intrigué fait
que m'avait dit un jour j'allais
j'allais faire ce que j'avais comme
drive depuis que ce jeune c'était
souhait de devenir entrepreneur ou soit
avocat cesser les deux oui l'avocat
s'était probablement par les sens
inconsciemment l influence que mes
parents avaient son moi maman le
beaucoup d'éducation puis à la fête
beaucoup à le passer beaucoup de temps
universités puis ma mère à ce jour vu
que j'ai et pas de baccalauréat ou quoi
que ce soit pensent encore que je vois
finir dans la rue de façon imminente
mais fake justement après québec parce
j'ai décidé de retourner à l'école
j'avais passé mon cégep je te retourne à
l'école antoine versé en tant que
candidat du jeu augmenter mes notes je
rentre en dois je me disais c'est
peut-être ça je voulais faire finalement
en cours de route je me suis rendu
compte que c'était plus programmer
parents fiers que pour moi
personnellement puis ensuite de 10
heures j'ai du site arte accès télécom
qui devenu axiaux pendant que j'étais en
droit on a eu une première ronde
d'investissement septembre 2010 est
de mon idole en fait d'entrepreneurs
c'est là un des entrepreneurs que j'aime
le plus au monde puis c'est xavier niel
c'est le fondateur de free en europe qui
ont des plus grosses compagnies de
télécommunications puis seuil aidant
c'est un milliardaire mais c'est très
terre à terre
sa femme c'est delphine arnault
l'héritière de louis vuitton lvmh
effectif je leur dirais pas que j'ai
vendu du pôle un genou quand j'étais
jeune
et
je voulais je voulais rentrer en contact
avec lui parce que en fait lui a fait
exactement ce qu'on veut faire au canada
puis c'est exploser le marché des
télécommunications puis offrir une
meilleure expérience des meilleurs prix
aux meilleurs services puis lui a fait
100 francs suisses pour ça que si vous
allez en europe vous voyez qu'il ya des
gens qui ont des forfaits à 2 99 euros
par mois avec 50g limitée partout dans
le monde c'est grâce et xavier puis moi
quand j'ai vu ça j'ai fait bâtir c'est
ce qu'on veut faire au canada il me faut
cette personne là avec nous tu y
retournes au début de ce qu'on avait
ouvert la parenthèse pour refaire un
petit peu l'histoire de l'occident le
faut le temps martèle membres de faire
sur tout deux têtes deux entreprises
derrière la cravate tintamarre te
demande d'installer le wef puis te dit
quelque chose et
2 ag2 expérience derrière la cravate
puis j'ai à ce moment là je suis comme
s'ils étaient en droit à l'université
goethe en droit université quand tu vis
pas ce problème là d'une problèmes de
connectivité ethernet bête tu prend pour
acquis l'internet que tameka de survie
c'est le centre de ton univers
le quand j'ai vu ça j'ai fait ça là
aucun rebond 5 en 2010 est très simple
que moins j'avais de la misère à étudier
le soir avec cette connexion internet là
ou quoi que ce soit salonique une fait
que j'ai appelé francis qui était
quelqu'un que je connaissais à peine qui
était qui travaillait chez bell à
l'époque qui était la seule personne que
je connaissais en télécommunications
puis est un vendeur chez bell où il
travaille un petit réglage des partants
des génériques est bien cuit c'est un
passionné de télécommunications de
réseautique de tous tout ce qui touche
la télécommunication puis je l'appelais
tout naïvement plus j'ai dit ah et
comment qu'on peut régler le problème de
mes parents puis francis ccc ainsi
quelqu'un de très énervé il ya beaucoup
de gestuelle pieds tu comprends moitié
ses idées capable parce qu'il parle
tellement envie qu'ils imaginent déjà ma
tout le monde peut y était comme hawaii
max pas compliqué on va sauter une tour
de télécommunications d'encours j'étais
par un pont va falloir un lien de 58 km
du mont bélair de blabla faire un lien
j'étais comme ok ok ça marche ça marche
fait on pile à la fin il fait bien la
scène afin qu'ils se fassent dans ses
rues sans convaincre c'était comme dans
leur co
allons-y fait que j'ai occupé par un ton
et à gré avec un projet pour pouvoir
déployer l'internet chez mes parents
puis en faisant ça on s'est dit il ya
pas juste mais par contre quand même le
fait qu'on va régler ce problème là pour
la communauté puis en tant que deux
jeunes de 23 ans 24 ans à l'époque naïf
on a monté un plan d'affaires compte
aller présenter à la ville de pont rouge
pour ce projet leur puits en efet le
pitch d'une vie on s'est préparé on
était prêts sont non répondent à toutes
les questions et que c'était jusqu'à
temps que la dernière question arrive du
conseil municipal qui disent c'est ben
beau votre projet je trouve ce printemps
simple comme vous voyez dans la salle ya
beaucoup d'intérêt par rapport à votre
projet mais votre territoire auquel vous
l'installez votre tour de des
communications ils ont mené agricole
dynamique vous pouvez rien construire
là-dessus fait que les allées dessus et
notre projet comme ça 1-2 soyons mais
quand on repartait bredouille dans le
parking puis on a tout fait pour s'en
aller comme d'un film mais quelqu'un qui
sortait de la salle en courant comme un
lego j'ai vraiment aimé votre moto petit
mais ce que vous vouliez forex été
observé que dans le comté de portneuf
qui la région auxquels mes parents
habitent il ya une vraie problématique
de connectivité internet moi je
travaille pour la mrc de portneuf ça
serait cool que vous veniez nous devons
à nos bureaux puis vous nous présenter
votre projet pour notre des
municipalités qui sont problématiques on
préfète vous a aidé dans ce projet le
fait qu on est allé rencontrer la merci
de portneuf ils nous ont présenté une
municipalité qui est très champêtre est
très très sexy du nom de
rivière-à-pierre quillan par mon papier
avait inscrit bon rivera pierre il ya
333 maison là bas puis y'a jamais
personne qui avait réussi à régler le
problème at il des collectifs internet
passé tellement éloigné des autres
municipalités que ça coûte excessivement
cher des pour dérouler de la fibre
jusque jusqu'à là bas ils ont dit les
gars savent autant d'ici on va vous
goûterez après un petit financement
trente mille dollars de subventions
50000 dollars de dettes puis vous allez
pouvoir allez vous amuser puis régler ce
problème le fait le boulot pour nous à
l'époque 4000 dollars c'était je pensais
rouler sur la fecq on a fait un lien du
mont bélair on utiliser la technologie
micro ondes on ne fait livrer un lien
internet au mont bélair à québec où ce
qu'ils avaient de la fibre optique on a
installé des antennes ans jusqu'à
arriver à la pierre de suspense et 55 km
à vol d'oiseau un fils de 55 non c'est
miss ronde c'est
ça par radiofréquence 6 10 a cédé au
micro ondes et puis tout se lisent la
fibre optique initial prends soin de toi
tu transmets le reste le res par la
technologie sans fil
qui veut que la fota mintsa à vol
d'oiseau faut que les deux les deux
antennes se voit fait qu'il faut que tu
fasses des
simulations pour voir c'est quoi
l'endroit le plus haut de la ville
comment tu peux t'assurer que les deux
se parlent plus des logiciels qui permet
de face mettez jamais sûr à 100% sur un
marché puis aligné des antennes
à 55 kilomètres de distance c'est pas
facile voit pas à l'oeil le malheur si
on n'avait pas d'argent pour payer des
montants de l'ain qui encore une fois je
vais avoir l'air d'un gars qui fait des
choses illégales à toutes les années
passent mais c'était moi le monteur de
lignes à fond puis je tenais auxerre je
t'avais 20 longueurs des escalades jeter
comme
commun comme hp qui m'a tant que tel a
besoin combien de tours 2 on a besoin
d'eux puis ensuite de tout de tout le
reste du réseau se déployait aussi par
micron donc on installe et mettons de
l'équipement par la suite dans le
clocher de l'église ensuite d'autres
dans d'autres endroits dans d'autres
terrains de la ville parce que tu sais
quand on installe un client l'internet
on installe une petite antenne sur son
toit qui pointaient vers nos torts
qu'ils avaient de l'accès à l'internet
quand ce ne sont pas sans un câble
jusqu'aux auteurs pierre seul qui avait
l'internet c'est comme ça que ça
fonctionne et c'est comme les tours
d'acier des anneaux le cas qui allume la
fox les chaque type de montage
c'est exactement ce que je veux dans ma
tête pour pouvoir garder la foi
en gros c'est ça qu'on a fait puis
finalement ça le super bien été on ne
régler la problématique dans trois
municipalités du comté de portneuf un
brin sauf que on était une équipe de
deux on avait pas de fond on n'avait pas
de sous on avait eu un petit
investissement aussi par la suite en
septembre 2017 mais dans le ton vous
autres les abonnés s'abonner à vos
services à vous c'est un peu sur le
regza revenus on avait un service à la
clientèle un numéro de téléphone tu t'es
mon cellulaire fait que ces jeux peuvent
pas être seul toit entraînement style
quatre heures devrait être seul toit
apprennent 17 à leurs clients apprennent
de parler quelqu'un puis le
faisait 2 puis quand fx entreprises
l'heure on utilisait ce bagage là pour
comprendre qu' il y avait une grosse
problématique de logiciels de comment
gérer des opérations en tant que
compagnie de télécoms qui se traduisait
un mauvaise expérience client mauvaise
année sa clientèle
mauvais prix
mauvaise structure de coûts dans une
compagnie télécommunications il n'y
avait pas d'automatisation puis nous on
essayait vu qu'on était juste une équipe
de 12 on essaie de trouver un logiciel
qui nous permet tait de gérer nos
opérations plus de gérer notre service
clients pour offrir un bon service à nos
clients parce qu'on n'avait pas les
moyens de le développer nos mains puis
quand on s'est rendu compte de ce bail
on s'est dit ah peut-être une plus
grande opportunité là on veut régler les
problématiques de connectivité internet
ne peut pas être concert on s'attaque
aux symptômes et non à la source du
problème c'est là que son effectif
pendant deux ans c'est là qu'en 2019 on
s'est dit
je pense que avec le pouvoir du logiciel
avec ce qu'on va développer en interne
on va être capable de prouver aux
canadiens qu'on a fait un meilleur
service de télécommunication sans même
toucher aux infrastructures physiques
puis on s'est dit que le différenciateur
en télécommunications n'était plus le
pays qui est déployée parce que ton
internet peu importe la technologie
qu'utilise si ça marche des satisfaits
c'est tout
mais en offrant une expérience 100%
digitale de devenir le premier
fournisseur internet 100% digitale au
canada puis mais c'est très différent la
technologie maintenant c'est quoi la
différence que je les dois par
différence de technologie c'est que
met-on vidéotron c'est du câble ouais
fait belle c'est la fibre qui en sus de
tout d'autres sites de technologie mais
que ce soit de la fibre ou du câble on
s'entend ne rien à cirer ce que tu veux
c'est que ça marche puis ça marche bien
puis une connexion internet sur une
commodité tu meurs pas avoir à se
soucier de cela - tu penses le mieux
c'est pour toi dans ta 18 heures c'est
quoi ce que nico admissibles non en fait
le nous c'est qu'on utilise la
technologie qu'avance un texte sur les
différents réseaux de télécommunication
gueugnon focus sur le logiciel pour
offrir la meilleure expérience client
léger soir quatre commandes en ligne
quand une connexion avec nous que ce
soit le service après-vente et c'est
avec nous c'est vraiment à l'inter c'est
grâce à notre expertise puis on a vu que
le crtc à cause que l'industrie des
communications enders d'un oligopole en
fait le crtc obligé les grands
télécommunicateurs a donné accès à leurs
réseaux qu'ils fassent des joueurs qui
voulaient offrir des meilleurs services
puis voir challenge et l'industrie
actuelle le statu quo en fait nous on
s'est dit notre prémices contrairement à
toutes les autres joueurs dans le marché
c'est justement le logiciel c'est le
futur en télécommunications c'est ce qui
va nous permettre
d'abord un edge compétitifs par rapport
à tout ce qui se fait dans le marché
puis c'était soit vraiment notre
première hypothèse vers 2019 on s'est
dit on va s'intégrer sur réseau de
vidéotron on va focus 100% sur
l'expérience digitale puis on va offrir
un meilleur service de cause à effet
c'est ce qu'on a fait puis en 2019 on
était une équipe de 5 3 développeurs
francis et moi français s'occuper de
l'aspect télécommunications restic et
c'est parce que quand même déployé une
certaine infrastructure réseau pour
pouvoir offrir nos services maskargo
rôle pour la simplifier le pauvre de
patch x assez souvent quand il n'y a pas
d'industrie s'est dit c'est la
complainte
nous on a un réseau dans un centre de
données qui est à montréal par exemple
sur les réseaux de vidéotron on bat
notre propre réseau puis on passe notre
internet dans les files de vidéotron ou
pour se rendre jusqu'à chez notre client
fait qu on loue de l'espace dans les
pubs de vidéotron pour pouvoir s'offrir
notre service internet sans avoir à
déployer l'infrastructure dans les rues
de lille aux mains de maître des furets
tour exactement fake qui en plus de ça
nous on développe la couche logicielle
pour pouvoir gérer site internet là pour
fort que le client peut gérer son
internet ses services que nous à l'inter
n'ont pu gérer les opérations
l'inventaire les informations clients
les paiements etc tout ce qui touche aux
2,2 du magasin magasinage en ligne
jusqu'à l'expérience a prévu puis donc
en 2019 on s'est dit on va on va
s'attaquer aux pratiques là on va
essayer notre hypothèse était en focus
ans sur l'expérience du talent car
d'offrir un meilleur service meilleure
connexion un meilleur prix puis c'est ce
qu'on s'est lancé on avait comme
projection de connecter de 2000 clients
la première année en 2010 9,1 finalement
dans les connecter 2000 on a commencé à
développer le logiciel en mars 2019 on a
collecté notre premier client en octobre
2019 ses sofas soirée d'un app store on
avait dix mille clients terre puis
aujourd'hui on est rendu à 30 mille
clients puis on est rendu à intégrer sur
le réseau de vidéotron sur le réseau de
rogers en ontario sur le réseau de chat
en colombie-britannique pour nos vies
l'alberta en février cette année puis
les maritimes sur les réseaux d'inscrits
d'ici la fin de l'année aussi la fin de
l'année 2000 et puis
qu'est-ce concrètement l'expérience
client comment comment qui est meilleur
que tout ce qu on a expérimenté jusqu'à
l'homme tombé il ya un sujet d'actualité
qui sépare intéressant pour vous donner
des données par rapport à papa est ce
juste la semaine passée il ya un rapport
qui était sorti qu'il ya encore 1 9%
d'augmentation de plainte des services
de télécommunications au canada puis
avait trois raisons majeures puis 88 %
de ces plaintes leur venaient de la
satisfaction client les trois raisons
principales étaient 1 la stabilité du
réseau des mauvaises ya des mauvaises
charge qu'une mauvaise divulgation des
termes et conditions d'utilisation
je pense que tout le monde puisse mettre
dans les souliers de quelqu'un qui a eu
à attendre plus d'une heure au service à
la clientèle et que c'est fait si on
compare les deux compagnies de gestion
immobilière tantôt mais je pense qu'ils
quittent barnes 2 à 4 5 personnes pour
pouvoir régler un problème mais c'est ça
on peut utiliser ça aussi dans
l'industrie des télécommunications puis
c'est quelque chose qui me quelque chose
de vraiment on dirait
qu'ils pas du tout de notre époque de
devoir appeler
quelqu'un pour changer un service chez
lui et qui cherche un peu présence le
dessus je parle
faute si je mets dans ma to do list
qu'il faut que j'appelle la banque ou
dans le passé une compagnie de
télécommunications le moment que je le
fais je parle 10 ans d'espérance de vie
c'est aussi simple que ça
c'est juste juste pensé faire un
virement mettons le il fallait aller à
la banque ou appeler quelqu'un c'est
comme tel accéder c'est trop simple et
trop facile tu peux demander du crédit
tu peux faire ce que tu veux avec ton
sur l'heure exacte donc donc nous c'est
vraiment ces trois points là en fait la
stub la stabilité du réseau en fait nous
on peut régler certains aspects de la
stabilité du réseau parce que notre
logiciel permet d'avoir
un système d' alerte qui nous permet de
voir quand la connexion du client par
exemple dans fait qu au lieu de toi ph
jamais ta connection tarifs chez vous
asseoir sa connexion fonctionne pas
puisque tu veux te connectes est un
problème mais nous on pourrait le voir
en amont puis on pourrait le diagnostic
est on prêt soit renvoyé une allée
notifiez faire et ph que genou il ya une
maintenance dans ton secteur où et
s'intéressent à votre bac at elle a dit
y a pas trop activités dans l'industrie
médicale initiation par rapport à ça il
va avoir des problématiques tout le
temps je veux dire à un service qui doit
être up 24 7 puis qui rendu un service
essentiel c'est sûr que ça peut pas
toujours roulé parfaitement en tout
temps mais la proactivité que tu amènes
dans comment du traité cuillère mais ça
c'est primordial aussi dans la
satisfaction des clients ensuite de sol
est le deuxième plus haut point c'est
les charges les mauvais charge at-on
qu'on nous ne te prie c'est le même on
ne jamais augmenter un prix de nos
clients depuis le début de l'histoire
éventuellement peut-être qu'avec
l'inflation votre foi on va devoir jeter
des prix comme n'importe quelle
entreprise mais on va viser le client
bande avance puis on va pas envoyer à
toutes les années avant noël une lettre
qui dit et bonjour dans le souci
d'améliorer nos services nous avons
décidé d'augmenter de 4 dollars l'année
prochaine un nouveau service qui on le
sait tout le monde que c'est de la
bullshit puis que c'est pas vrai donc
son rex au problème longue on règle le
problème de prix aussi qui fluctue on
n'a pas de promotions temporaires on n'a
pas de promotion tape à l'oeil qui est
bien avec nous là on va dans votre donné
notre service pendant six mois puis
après ça on va
bosser êtes à maison tellement que le
plan anti moi et ça c'est assez
incroyable mais je les fois que j'ai
fait à faire pour justement les studios
aussi le test de convoquer les six
premiers mois c'est quand même c'est
raisonnable le prix plus appréciés après
six mois c'est comme c'est quasiment 33
% d'augmentation le président christian
puis le prix justement est-ce que vous
êtes plus bottes la compétition ouais on
est plus bas que la conversion puis nous
en fait d'un point de vue
financier un autre avantage
concurrentiel qu'on a c'est la
transparence il ya pas de transparence
en télécommunications nous tue pas les
sonates site auxi au moins six ans tu
peux aller dans l'onglet transparence je
peux voir c'est quoi la ventilation nos
coûts combien vaut axiaux convient pas
aux gros joueurs puis pourquoi on
cherche chiffré ces prix là il nous nos
prix le note thèse de prix c'est pas
compliqué on joue un jeu long terme dans
tout ce qu'on fait chez axioma je suis
ici pour les 25 prochaines années on
jouera jeu long terme avec nos clients
aussi ont fait pas un sou noir avant 24
manches et avec notre client dans un
autre pays bas qui sur 24 mois fake nous
c'est pas compliqué on ne regarde les
coûts d'accès à notre réseau du
fournisseur au québec c'est vidéotron
par exemple on met toutes nos dépenses
on regarde combien ça nous prend pour
être break-even après 24 mois puis nous
notre première c'est que soyez avec nous
pendant 24 mois vous prouver notre
valeur car cela nous on va faire un
profit là dessus pour pour continuer à
vous offrir les meilleurs services qui
sont on peut voir cela pendant longtemps
à l'avancé conscience est incroyable et
éthiques quand tu t'appelle pour te
désabonner d'un service la
somme des abonnés à mais là on va on va
déraper 40% de la facture c'est comment
je vois qu'il ya un nouvel les
promotions à votre dossier possible
c'est même principe que dans certains
sites douteux quand vient le temps de se
désabonner ça tombe bien plusieurs
gratuité
c'est un autre problème c'est au final
c'est pas normal qu ils vendraient de
sorte qu'avec des amis subitement
supprimer vos pieds autour de la table
si vous avez une des amies plate vous
parlez de vos services internet fixe
vous rendez vous comme tu payes par mois
mais ses recettes
e mais que finalement tu te rends compte
que vous avez le même service avec la
même compagnie puis vous avez une
facture de faire ça pollue pas dans
n'importe quoi dans n'importe quel
commerce de détail ou quoi que ce soit
pour avoir un produit expie si tu l'as
acheté dans le même temps une prime de
notre profession sur la même chose
difficile transparence absolue que de
transparence qui créa business à 14 ans
j'ai
appris mon expérience qu'on va être la
compagne et la plus transparente au
monde on le fait et puis ça c'est une
philosophie qu'on a c'est transparence
radicale on a quatre valeurs puis la
plus puissante jusqu'à présent c'est la
transparence radicale puis à l'internet
chez nous nos enfants nos employés
savent c'est quoi le salaire de tout le
monde la compagnie c'est 100% public
puis on pensait initialement le déploie
le le dit lui-même au public à
l'extérieur de la compagnie j'ai fait un
recensement dans toute la compagnie puis
il ya des membres de notre équipe qui
sont arrivés depuis qu'ils nous
expliquer que ben c'est tellement de
tabou puisque c'est un sujet qui me
tient à coeur tellement tabou l'argent
au canada puis combien que les gens gang
qu'il ya des jacques qui sentait qu'il
ya laborde et d'aider des moments
vraiment particulier avec leur entourage
par rapport à leur salaire par rapport
s'il savait si leur entourage avec y
gagner autant d'argent ou que
je sais pas quoi y allait avoir des des
moments plate ne voulait pas divulguer
ce fait que nous
on est hervé avec la fin la philosophie
la transparence radicale que
la transparence radicale devrait
toujours respecter la vie privée
des gens avec qui on travaille donc on
garde la transparence radicale interne
chez nous on divulgue les salaires comme
ça les gens si
doomst travailler chez nous puis
doublette chéquier et je suis bien payé
etc mais on va aller voir c'est quoi
toutes les saveurs de thé de tes
collègues petit peu tu peux te faire une
tête puis nous on paye top du marché
personnel fait qu on paie on on essaie
d'avoir la plus grande densité talents
dans notre organisation fait qu'on paye
en conséquence
c'est rendu qu'on bien maintenant j'en
ai rendu 81 91 puis l'homme
on a parlé un petit peu des rondes de
financement le mais vous avez quand même
des bacs et parle par du monde solide le
fait qu'on peut on parler on peut
revenir sur sur le but je parlais tout à
l'heure le ouais saviez comment ça s'est
passé et puis pourquoi vous vous offrez
vous avez flag et dans le fond d'avis
quand c'est quand même une belle
histoire parce que c'est à quel moment
exactement dans l'histoire que tu me
racontes et xavier a investi en
septembre 2010 est convenu comme ses
vrais débuts puis je me rappelle encore
du pitch que j'ai fait c'était de régler
la problème de connectivité internet à
guy viala tiers l'ipo fait un gros patch
sexy dont on va conquérir le monde j'ai
dit hey je suis passionné par régler le
problème interne est de 336 turquie lors
jouin en premier j à ce moment là j ai
même pas parlé directement en fait ce
que je m'avait rendu compte c'est que
quand j'ai fait mes recherches et xavier
j'ai fait faut que je trouve un moyen
d'abord ce gala avec nous autres
puis j'ai vu au moins une maman qui
avait pas si longtemps que ça partie un
fonds d'investissement en stand up
s'applique kima ventures qui faisaient
des chèques de 150 millions us parce
qu'en europe près cent cinquante mille
euros puis j'ai fait tabarouette faut
que je trouve un moyen de rentrer en
contact avec avec lui fait que la marge
porte d'entrée c'était par le manager du
fonds le kiss émergent de la
rochebrochard fait que j'ai écouté
pendant une semaine toutes les podcasts
que je pouvais mettre sous la main de
jean puis j'ai envoyé un email
personnalisé en expliquant notre mission
ce qu'on voulait faire et c'est heureux
ils m'ont répondu j'en parlais xavier je
te revient et mais revenez avec plein de
questions on ait fait un zoom à distance
avec leur thème puisque dans le maillon
décidé de nous bac et à l'intérieur de
moi
puis ils nous ont fait le chèque qui
nous ont supportés pts
ccdg recommande à toutes les
entrepreneurs qui est caustique kima
ventures investit dans tout les
entrepreneurs de la francophonie d'un
point de vue mondial
puis c'est les mains entre les maires
investissant qu'on aurait pu avoir puis
le dernièrement baisse la compagnie
modèle d'affaires évolué on a pivoté
complètement onu 202 peur douleur
d'entrepreneurs d'essayer de faire
monter une compagnie qui monte paca
qu'on a pu voter 7 et le contraire on
été victimes d'un nexus et puis on est
on est une croissance qu'on s'attendait
pas d'histoire interne puis l'a
dernièrement on était à septembre
l'année dernière on était acceptée hawaï
comme une erreur qui est l'incubateur de
startups les plus prestigieux au nom de
bienne be tu dors d'acheter plein de
compagnies qui composent ils ont l'idée
de cette compagnie et petites
entreprises le des petites entreprises
qui s'en trouveraient familial
normand même pas
puis on est accepté à ça en septembre
l'année passée puis moi c'était un de
mes rêves d'enfance comme leader
je regarde l'état des programmes le bloc
de programmes qui les créateurs de white
comme des leurres mike aussi bon tous
ses cd gère l'industrie puis je rêve un
jour d'aller là puis on est accepté on
était la première entreprise de québec
la ville de québec a été acceptée hawaï
comme des livres d'histoire de tous les
temps il ya quelques entreprises de
montréal qui l'ont fait aussi avant nous
puis on est allés jeter à l'habiter sim
en californie pour cette expérience là
ils ont donné un petit financement puis
caen qui nous ont accepté en septembre
on n'avait pas assez de fonds pour se
rendre au programme je n'avais pas assez
d'argent pour n'avait pas c'est de
l'argent qui se rendent au croyant parce
que nous notre modèle d'affaires fait
qu'on investit dans le client on
investit 2 1 dans le client fait que si
on a un mois super super bon puis qu'on
connaît qu 10000 clients mais de
l'argent on parle d'argent commentaire
enfin sur le long terme ces vecteurs
faut régler ses problèmes de financement
le puits avant notre dernière grosse
ronde de financement on n'avait jamais
eu plus que trois mois à vivre dans
l'entreprise effectué c'était le tout
pour le tout puis moi c'était un
charmant cdbn youtube
bombes à gaz qu'on ait fait
ça pas toujours été facile vraiment peur
puis on s'est dit ben nous on va aller
en californie on va aller dans ces
combats les ont va les rencontrer les
grands investisseurs du monde puis
justement avoir les moyens de nos
ambitions pour le futur pie j'aurais pu
besoin de faire des crises dans ses
traits à minuit le soir en me disant
belmont entreprises exposantes ronde
sauf qu'on n'avait pas assez de fonds
pour se rendre en janvier puis ils nous
ont accepté avoir comme leader ils nous
ont dit baye
on croit ce que vous faites puis on
pense que vous allez trouver des
solutions mais on vous accepte puis
advienne que pourra fait qu'on est
accepté on a levé une ronde de
financement
entre-temps qui nous a permis d'avoir
assez d'argent jusqu'à fin avril
pour pouvoir passer tout le process le
processus de ouakam leader puis voit
comme une erreur quand ça marche c'est
qu'il ya
des tas de workshop à toutes les
semaines ce travail avec des partenaires
qui ont créé des grosses entreprises
sinon passez une note postée le
cofondateur de yahoo mettons qui nous a
aidés là dedans puis
ensuite de tout ça à la fin du pitch
c'est démodé que ça s'appelle pichi
pitch à toutes les plus grands
investisseurs en technologie au monde
avec nous on savait dit mais on continue
notre croissance on continue à bien
s'occuper de nos clients pour avoir de
plus en plus de clients puis on veut
lever une grosse faute de financement a
demandé c'est ce qu'on ait fait pis
cette journée là onu le support des
xavier qui revenu qui est fait eh ben
moi je vous suis depuis 2010 est ça me
fera plaisir de l'idée votre ombre de
financement fait qu avant des modèles a
gelé le matin avant je me mettais à
peach et à tous les investisseurs et
modibo est parfait nous on élevé on a
levé 25 millions canadiens et d'équité
en juin dernier puis dit mais moi je
reprends de la moitié de votre nom de
financement fait qui a pris 12 points 5
millions faible avec des mots d une
restait la moitié de l'autre on a close
et pendant ce temps leurs piles en plus
on avait un géant de l'industrie des
télécoms questions qui nous baquet on
avait loué comme une erreur qui équipe
qu'on avait le système de comme welcome
des lieux qui super reconnu dans
la part des investisseurs fait que le
12.5 millions et kad aller chercher
d'autres investisseurs américains puis
mondiaux qui sont
encore une fois si pâle impressionnant
si on ne le font de wonder croquis et
jeffrey katzenberg le fondateur
d accès à des gens qui sont comme plus
rare nature exceptionnelle puis on a
réussi à lever cette ronde de
financement l'appui en plus de son nom
de lever de la dette avec nos
partenaires financiers au québec
desjardins desjardins capital etc québec
puis là maintenant on est sept pour les
les 36es les 36 prochains mois qui
lobait ring merci de pas être dans la
maison
en même temps je me dis ça amène un
autre un autre type de stress ça doit
amener quand même une jarre de pression
assez incroyable sens ça se fait que tu
dois te situes tu dors mieux parce que
tu te demande pas que ce soit manger le
lendemain matin compagnie va encore
exister mais c'est quand même la
pression de fournir seul c'est c'est
clair que le stress de performance
devient de plus en plus élevés puis 7-7
confronte aussi at-on m
il ya un concept que j'appelle le
magical thinking dans ta vie autant
personnelle que professionnelle que
c'est comme un bain le jour que je vais
avoir x je vois est heureux maintenant
je me sentirai y oui jours que je vais
avoir ma la blonde parfaite bien je
voyais parfait maintenant que j'arrive à
une problème de steam de souhaiter que
c'était le jour que ma compagnie va
faire tel nombre de revenus l'oeuvre est
heureux mais tu vas me dire que c'est
exactement ce qui se passe
la vérité c'est que c'est complètement
l'opposé puis au contraire c'est qu'un
fait confronté aux magical thinking
piqué je disais moi je me disais le jour
que jeter un jour que je lèverai 25
millions $ frais comme jadis pour l'un
d'eux s'est réglé le roi du monde va
être le gars le plus confiait l'histoire
la planète terre pis au contraire quand
j'ai levé 7 rondes la première semaine
après c'était une des semaines les plus
difficiles de toute ma vie je sa cause
de tout l'est le faire d'autre avec
multiples travaille plus la pression des
dernières années que j'étais comme sur
l'adrénaline de toujours levé du
financement puisse assurer que nos
clients soient satisfaits de cette
erreur ben la semaine après c'était
comme un relâchement de cette pression
l'homme en même temps ça laisse place à
de nouvelles le pression fait que ça a
commenté un
d'émotion particulière à cette veine là
qui m'a fait que je me sentais
particulier tpiy maintenant je suis je
suis plus motivé que jamais mais je suis
plus conscient que jamais que toutes les
stimuli externes de qlailé les ce que je
souhaite personnellement l'externe de ma
vie mais c'est pas une recette pour le
succès ou paume on estime de soi au pour
régler des problèmes et c'est perfect ça
vient pour répondre à ta question ça
vient avec une nouvelle pression qui est
maintenant mais on a établi un plan
d'affaires on a des objectifs qui sont
extrêmement ambitieux puis maintenant
mais c'est un autre équipe d exécuter
ensemble c'est c'est le plus beau métier
de l'histoire du monde de pouvoir faire
ça parce que c'est un type de créer
quelque chose de nouveau puis toute ton
équipe ensemble se créer quelque chose
de nouveau
mais l'entreprise monde en général fait
que ben et fait donner des coups de
poing en face à toutes les semaines il
faut tuerait jeu sans conséquence
si vous avez des objectifs ambitieux
c'est quoi maintenant vos objectifs à
moyen et long terme en fait nous on a
décidé commencé comme étant un
fournisseur internet indépendant le
premier fonction est indépendant
digitale au canada ont des objectifs ont
de l'ambition mondiale éventuellement
puis on veut devenir le leader en
connectivité au monde dangereux
connectivité c'est quoi c'est juste une
façon plus sexy de dire télécom c'est
juste que télécom c'est un mot qu'on
pense qu'edf est maintenant utilisent le
terme collective compass des télécoms
grecs ont exulté si on part tout juste
de connectivité internet tout mais juste
oui parce que maintenant tous les types
de services de connectivité passe par
l'internet autant la télévision que les
services mobiles le 5 juin qui fabrique
mettons-les
c'est lui là tout ça leur apporte
exactement
nous on veut devenir la première
plateforme de connectivité internet au
monde puis nous ce qu'on fait c'est
qu'on bâtit un logiciel en ce moment
neuf des services internet résidentiels
mais éventuellement on veut offrir
toutes les types de services de
connectivité aux clients et que vous
arrivez sur notre plateforme en fonction
de wes que tu habites c'est quoi tes
besoins de connectivité et c'est
rassurant des informations puis aux
ksistof le meilleur service de
connectivité en fonction des besoins
puis juste pour prendre un petit thé ben
heck pas à passer pour vous parler un
peu de notre vision sur le long terme
puis c'est drôle parce que c'est une
conversation que j'ai eue avec ma grand
mère qui a déterminé comment je vois le
futur dénis télécom duos avec ma grand
mère mon grand père
il ya deux ans environ j'ai demandé à
mon grand papa grand grand mère j'ai
pris justement une lumix quand c'est une
cam comme ça puis j'ai dit j'aimerais si
vous filmez puis vous posez toutes les
questions de votre vie ce genre comment
vous avez grandi et évolué etc j'ai
passé deux heures avec qui mon grand
père m'a grand marty il parlait de tout
le jeu leur poser des questions même
sort combien de partenaires sexuels ma
grand mère avait eu puis jarmon g a
aussi fait des trucs de
[Rires]
ces questions puis juste de voir comment
mes grands parents étaient nés dans une
ville qu'il n'y avait même pas de
l'automobile puisque appel du premier
gars qui avait un autre mobile qui à mon
grand père jouer au hockey dehors
l'hiver avec du caca de cheval jour et
congelés comme pas que c'était faux puis
aussi commun qui prenaient leur british
était un banc en bois ce que toute la
famille était présente ici dans la même
équipe plus jeune il ramassait toute
l'eau sale tout le monde puis amener ça
sent vraiment mon grand père ma grand
mère se sont mis à parler de
l'électricité réussi puisque les
appareils qui avaient qui avaient été
connectées à l'électricité à l'époque
qui était cadre les nommer cet égard de
dire mais moi j'avais tels que le
téléphone connecté c'est drôle parce que
ça m'a fait faire un parallèle sur
l'internet et les appareils qui sont
connectés à l'internet puis en date
d'aujourd'hui ben on peut le canadien
moyen ou l'usagé moyen pour nos mains
sur le doigt le doigt sur le bout de ses
doigts c'est quoi qui est connecté à
l'internet j'ai mon portable j'ai un
ipad si je fais ici géant google ont -
alex augé d'autres affaires mais tu peux
quand même les nommer que ceux ci mais
aujourd'hui j'essaye de nos mines tout
ce que je possède qui est connecté à
l'électricité je pourrai pas tout le
mans puis nous ce qu'on croit ce que il
va avoir 100 mille ex plus de deux vice
qui vont être connectés à l'internet
dans le futur puis ses deux vice là vont
nécessiter des différentes formes de
connexion et pourront pas juste dépendre
d'une connexion cellulaire 50 pièces par
mois pour être connectés il ya des
objets intelligents qui vont les villes
intelligentes fort besoin de center pour
les parkings pour la qualité de l'air
pour toutes ces affaires là ça va tout
nécessité des besoins que l'activité
puisque ça fait c'est qu'il ya des
compagnies actuellement dans le monde
qui sont en train de développer des
nouveaux réseaux qui sont en train de
revoir la structure économique de
comment déployer ses réseaux le tas des
compagnies en crypto comme iridium qui
déploient des hotspots pour tout ce qui
est à outils etc tandis qu'on les
compagnies de satellites de bassa orbite
comme stirling puis spacek ce fait et
sait mettre personne qui s'attaque à
l'accessibilité de ces différents
réseaux puis nous c'est ce qu'on veut
s'attaquer notre mission c'est créer une
égalité d'opportunités qu'on veut créer
une accessibilité de toutes ces réseaux
de télécommunication qu'on veut remettre
la couche de logiciel qui permet aux
clients la plateforme d'avoir accès à
ces réseaux lieu de la forme la façon la
plus simple possible donc c'est vraiment
notre futur c est ce qu on s'en va en ce
moment on commence on a des croûtes à
manger on ne te retourne pas internet
100% digitale pour des services internet
mais sachez que cheikh personnes
s'abonnent cherchons actuellement c'est
vers le conserver c'est ce qu'on peut
faire avec action
pour les gens qui nous écoutent les
autres sortent sans fil qui vont
entendre parler de kyo dans les
prochaines semaines dans les prochains
mois à travers la collaboration de
question c'est quoi ton ton élèves le
pitch pour pour occuper au louvre qui
change de services mhcs auxi on est le
fournisseur internet avec les prix le
plus juste et raisonnable on a la
meilleure expérience client de toute
l'industrie cité tanner d'abondantes à
toulouse d'avoir appelé ton fournisseurs
puis d'avoir à négocier avec plus du
seuil des biens sociaux les prix que
soit son attitude si les prix que tu vas
voir on affluent mais a plus d'industrie
du poème brickdown exactement notre
structure de coûts on est transparent à
100%
puis on veut changer les choses en
télécommunications je pense qu'il ya
un problème encore plus grâce d'un point
de vue sociétal sur ce qui se passe en
ce moment des oligopoles ou des
monopoles c'est jamais bon pour la
démocratie puis en ce moment mais les
grosses compagnies de télécommunication
c'est les compagnies les plus puissantes
au canada c'est les compagnies les plus
fortes en termes de l'aube et puis en ce
moment c'est on utilise l'argent des
contribuables pour subventionner ces
compagnies là pour que ces compagnies-là
augmente le prix la facture des compètes
des canadiens à toutes les années puis
nous on veut faire le contraire on veut
on utilise l'argent privé des gens qui
croient en nous pour pouvoir baisser les
factures de tous les canadiens
éventuellement puis c'est vraiment ce
qu'on veut faire pour n'utilise le
logiciel pour réduire nos coûts
d'opération pour offrir une meilleure
expérience client un meilleur service si
vous allez voir sur plan aube si vous
allez voir sur google vous allez voir
une review vous allez voir qu'on est la
compagnie qui élimine review au canada
dans l'industrie reste extinction très
cool paraît très cool pourrait vraiment
crise ou bravo pour pour tout ce qu'ils
avaient accompli s'est rapidement jamais
embrassé le tout début que ça c'est
extrêmement prometteur et excitant
londres et qui est bravo
merci au cours la collaboration aussi
avec la sans filtre très très
certainement que ça va résonner avec les
règles aux hotspurs
début oui
[Musique]
merci de publier
du contenu excellent tu as tout un
podcast convient
oui
si vous voulez plus de contenu excellent
comme ce que vous venez d'entendre aller
sur une pétillante le pétrole vous
abonner pour trop de leur part mais
aussi trop de la whey trois pièces par
morlaàs par mois ils avaient les pattes
carte en avance acquise avec les
premiers de votre groupe d'amis à vous
écouter les podcasts qu'ils allaient
avoir pouvoir avoir une avance quand
vous allez tirer la dynamique entre les
amis soltane avons une avance sur les
jobs en avance sur tous les toits mais
avec pétillante une avance sur
l'humanité complète en plus en plus
parce que lâcher le podcast su ni voulu
nous entendre josé davantage on fait des
encore moins de filtres à préchac
podcast avec là on vient de finir de
tourner le podcast on va en jaser on va
te filer nicole non nicole il est
maintenant évident comme le fit le
travail la place de taza taille est là
mais on jase on parle de conversion
qu'on m'aide à voir mais ce si vous
voulez avoir accès
mais heureusement pour nous
malheureusement pour vous c'est exclusif
sur pétule il faut s'abonner abonnez
vous